It's that time of the year again, it's the Nobel prizes.
Always turns my phone up. You'd never know, but again,
overlooked. Yeah. Just needs to check the number.
I called it. Yes.
I'm feeling a bit smug about this because about five minutes before the
announcement, I suddenly had this feeling who was going to win and sure enough,
they did too. At least they won half the prize anyway.
And the other half of the prize went to a guy called Jim people.
And a good call. Let's us. See Jim peoples get past the Nobel prize.
He's regarded, I think as the father of modern cosmology.
Did you put a bet on or anything I should have done? Shouldn't I really, yeah.
But no, I didn't. And it was literally five minutes before the announcement.
It wasn't that clever prediction because I was certainly,
wasn't the only person predicting it. And it's been,
they've been sort of one of the runners and riders for a number of years now,
but I sort of thought it was their time. It's a slightly strange, uh, award.
And actually,
so the citation reads was awarded for contributions to our understanding of the
evolution of the universe and Earth's place in the cosmos,
which could be pretty much for anything really,
because that covers pretty much everything there is. Um,
but Jim Peebles is a cosmologist, um,
and is really one of the tiring founding figures of modern cosmology.
Um, in that he did a lot of the work. He was part of the group that was, um,
predicting the existence of the cosmic microwave background.
He did a lot of work about the growth of structure in the universe. Uh,
the impact of dark matter on how structure would grow. So really, I mean, he is,
if you,
if you teach a course on cosmology in large part of you're talking about his
work.
Model, which is fitting the data so well,
has his influence on every single part of it.
He is a theorist,
but he's one of those theorists who actually maintains a very close link to the
observation. So some of his work has actually he's written papers,
which are presenting observational data,
but more in a fairly theoretical framework.
So you would think of him as a theoretical.
He's just demonstrated that in modern cosmology,
these are the key ingredients we look like we need. And he,
he was there at the start of each one of them playing a role.
So he can be properly regarded as the father of the subject.
And the expert says that they're on your board of modern
cosmology. That's what I decided to come into the tutorial today.
We have tutorial system here at Nottingham where all the first years get to have
a, there's usually six in the group. I screwed up.
I had to do 12 cars. And so I thought, well,
you've got to tell them about the Nobel prize. At least the bit I know about it.
If you were talking about Jim Peebles, you wouldn't say, Oh,
he did so-and-so because there's just so much he's contributed.
So the other half of the prize was shared between Michelle Maya and DDA Cato,
and they worked on studying exoplanets. They still work on studying exoplanets.
So planets outside the solar system, um, and it was awarded for, and that,
let me get the exact wording here for the discovery of an exoplanet orbiting,
a solar type star.
So it was really their discovery in 1995 was what kicked off the entire
field of exoplanet studies.
Cause like exoplanets, these days are like candy aren't they they're like,
you know.
There are many, many thousands of them at that point. There was only one,
actually that's not quite true because there were other planets and that's,
it's interesting, the way they've worded the citation.
They said an exoplanet orbiting, a solar type star.
The first exoplanet was actually found, uh, orbiting, uh,
pots on a neutron star rotating neutron star,
which is a very weird system and no one really expected to find planets around
saws. Um, and so it was clearly something very strange. And so,
although it was interesting, it was like everyone was well,
it's nothing like the solar system.
So it's not really a planet in the sense that we would understand it, the rule.
So tentative discoveries of planets, orbiting, giant stars that preceded,
uh, the myo and kilo discovery.
But this was really the first announcement of one,
which we would sort of equate with something like the solar system.
So it was a solar type star,
very like the sun with the planet in orbit around it.
Do you happen to know what star was, was, it was obviously a nearby.
It was, uh, it's 51. Pegasus is the star and the planet is called 51,
Pegasus B it's about 50 light years away.
It's very ordinary stars and say it's a G type star.
So very light the sun a little bit more massive.
I think at 1.1 times the mass of the sun is a tiny bit more massive,
but really almost a twin of the sun, very bog standard kind of star.
What method did they use to just discover it?
So they use this, uh, radio velocity method. I mean,
there are now a whole slew of methods that are used for,
for discovering and studying exoplanets,
but one of the foundational techniques and the one that made this first
discovery was this radial velocity technique,
wherever if you've got a star and you think of a planet in orbit around it,
the sort of simple picture is the sun. The star is stationary in the middle,
on the planets orbiting around,
but of course they're actually tugging each other and sort of orbiting around
their mutual center of gravity.
What that means is that the planet is tugging the star backwards and forwards as
well as the, uh, the star tugging the planet backwards and forwards.
So the star is actually oscillating.
And so sometimes it's moving towards you and sometimes it's moving away from you
and by studying the spectra of the star and looking at those little dips,
whether a spectral lines in the star, you can see whether they're being shifted,
Doppler shifted towards the red end of the spectrum or the blue end of the
spectrum. So you measure that backwards and forwards wobble of the star.
And that gives you a measure of the mass of the thing that's orbiting around it,
as well as how rapidly it's orbiting around it,
by how quickly the thing oscillates backwards and forwards.
You know, that's a, that's a good method. I imagine.
I imagine that method had been thought of for quite a while and all the
astronomers in the world have access to telescopes and telescope time.
What did the scientists do that made them able to be first? Like what,
what method or trick or idea that they have that made them the winners?
So there's a couple of aspects here. Firstly,
people weren't really looking that hard at the time because there was no
expectation that you'd actually be able to detect much because we had this.
So if you think about what's easy, what's easy to detect. In this case,
you want something where there's a strong gravitational pull between your planet
and the star to target a long way. So it's got to be a big planet.
So there's two things. You want it to be a big planet. So it's massive.
So it'll talk with think backwards, forwards,
and actually you want them close together.
So the polar gravity is strong so that, that the movements are bigger.
And so what you'd really want is a planet like Jupiter close to the star.
Now at the time we only knew about one solar system and Jupiter in our solar
system is a long way out as is the way with scientists. You know,
if you've only got one example of something,
you convince yourself that that's the way the universe works.
So we had all these ideas at the time,
back in the 1990s and before the actually Jupiter,
like planets only existed in the outer reaches of solar systems and things close
to their stars of rural little things like mercury and earth,
which you wouldn't be able to detect. And so because of that,
there wasn't really a huge expectation that we'd be able to detect this kind of
effect and what these guys actually found was something that's about half the
massive Jupiter, very close to a star. And so actually,
and subsequently of course we found many of these hot Jupiter like planets.
So Jupiter like planets, which are close to the star.
And so it turns out that actually the universe doesn't work the way we thought
it did back then.
And there are mechanisms where even if a big planet forms of a long way out in
the solar system,
there are many mechanisms by which you can kind of migrate inwards towards its
star. Um,
so they found something that no one was really that much expecting to find, um,
which is why there wasn't a huge rush to try and find these things.
The other thing is they had some very clever instrumentation.
They actually built a custom built spectrograph that allow them to measure very
small Doppler shifts. They were down at sort of tens of meters per second,
that they were measuring these wobbles in these stars,
which did require very good instrumentation, very stable instrumentation,
where you can actually calibrate things with that kind of accuracy to really
measure those very small shifts.
So you couldn't have just had like an off the shelf night of VLT and have found
it sort of.
You probably could now with VLT, but in the 1990s, no,
you really wanted a custom built into it. It wasn't on that larger telescope.
It was, I think it was a two meter telescope. So even by then those standards,
the standards of the 1990s, it wasn't a particularly huge telescope,
but it was just a very clever spectrograph and they were looking for something
that no one else was really looking for.
As an astronomer. And you're an astronomer in the nineties. I was,
do you kick yourself and think, Oh, I could have done that.
That would have been like a week's work and I could have,
I could have been the one.
So the interesting thing is before their paper in the 1990s,
in the 1980s, let me show you another. So let me show you their paper.
So here's their paper published in 1995,
a Jupiter mass companion to a solar type style Nobel prize.
And it's, you know, it's actually not a particularly long paper.
It's not got many pretty pictures in it. A few graphs.
Not even a picture of the star, even a picture.
No, nothing spectacular about it at all. I mean, you know,
nice looking data that here's the, so here's the,
the wobble backwards and forwards of the star.
So sometimes it's going away from us sometimes it's coming towards us and you
can see, so the here's the scale 50 meters per second.
So this small ships that you're actually imagining here,
so that's the wobble that they were measuring. So here's the interesting,
that was the 1990s in 1989. This paper came out
the unseen companion of telephone number, a probable Brown dog.
And it turns out they had actually also discovered a Jupiter like planet he's on
there as well. He's actually, my always is on there as well.
So he's one of the authors, but the, the primary mover,
this guy called Dave Latham was actually in an office just over the corridor
from me at the time. Cause I was a PhD student and he was a proper,
serious scientist at that point, uh, at the CFA in Boston,
he wasn't very excited about this result. I mean, he was a bit excited,
but he was actually, you know, because, and again,
it comes back to the fact that no one was expecting to find planets.
And the reason why he didn't know that he'd found a planet.
So Brown doors is sort of one up from planets, they're sort of failed stars.
And no one was, you know, people were expecting to find Brown doors.
Cause we find binary stars quite a lot of the time and they have different mass
ratios and it wouldn't be terribly surprising if once in a while the little one
turned out to be not quite making it as a star.
So people were not that surprised to be finding stars with Brown dwarfs in orbit
around them because they're basically just very closely related to binary stars
that we know exists, binary it's one half of it's kind of failed to ignite.
So one half is a star.
The other half didn't quite make it because they weren't expecting to find
planets. He convinced himself he hadn't found a planet.
And the reason why there's an ambiguity, because you might think, well,
you know, we know what masses Brown dwarves are.
We know what massive planets I wouldn't have known.
It turns out there's an ambiguity in this method.
And the ambiguity in this method is I kind of drew this when I was waving my
hands around. I did it like that,
but we don't know whether the system's like that or whether it's sort of,
I can't do it that way, that way like that. And of course,
if the planets orbiting that way,
you don't see that the star is still moving it's,
but it's being tugged in the plane of the sky.
So you don't see these Doppler shifts. So this is ambiguous.
And of course you can have anything in between.
So actually if you see a certain movement, it could be like, uh, if it's,
you know, you see a certain movement, it could be a relatively low mass thing.
That's in the plane of the sky. So we see all the movement or the style,
or it could be, it's almost in a much more massive thing.
And actually this thing's jerking around all over the place,
but we don't see most of the motion.
Cause most of it's in the plane of the sky rather than towards the.
You've got to get lucky. It's kind of,
you need it to be punching you in the face rather than wobbling around to get
the biggest signal.
You really want to be lucky and just catch, catch the thing edge on.
So you see the biggest signal because there's less ambiguity. You,
you can't tell really directly from the observation,
whether you're seeing a Brown dwarf kind of in the plane of the sky,
close to the plane of the sky or a planet close to edge on.
And because they had this expectation that they shouldn't be finding these
planets,
they convinced themselves that they were seeing a Brown door star binary fairly
close on.
And it was a bit unlikely because actually it has to be surprisingly close to
face on for it to work, but they sort of convinced themselves.
They do actually say somewhere in the paper or it could be a large planet.
So they do actually at least make, you know, say we might've found a planet.
The extra thing that Maya and Kayla did is they also looked at the
properties of the star.
So they actually could measure how fast the star is rotating because can see one
half of it. If it stars rotating, one half of it's coming towards you,
the other half going away from you. And so you can actually see the,
what you ended up seeing is a kind of a broadening of the lines.
So instead of seeing the line wobbling,
you see part of the line being shifted one way, part of it, the other way,
the net effect of that as you see a slightly broader line,
so you could measure the rotation at the star, kind of the, the, the at least.
But again, this is the same thing. Like,
is it a star that's rotating in the plane of the sky or is it rotating edge on,
but they knew some of the properties of the star.
You could just make observations of it, finding out what kind of star it is.
And we know how fast stars typically actually rotate that are of that type.
So they have this measurement of this kind of one component of how fast the
things are rotating.
And that could be either a very fast rotating star that's sort of pole on,
or it could be a relatively slowly rotating star. That's Adrian,
but we know intrinsically how fast I was like this actually rotate from that.
You can figure out that actually this system is relatively close to age on.
So there's one more leap here,
which is that as long as the stars axis of rotation is the same as the planet's
axis of rotation, which for example, it is pretty much in the solar system.
The sun is rotating about kind of the same access that the solar system is.
Then that actually tells you that the system has to be relatively close to
Adrian. And once you've got that, then you know, you've found a planet.
So that was the sort of the extra bit that I guess is what really got them,
the Nobel prize.
Plus actually just the confidence to say we found something that no one expected
to find.
So in the future of one day, we go and visit other systems and other planets,
and we can somehow do this. This will be this plant,
this particular Nobel prize on a,
be a good one to visit wouldn't it it'd be like a historic one.
It'd be like visiting, like for humanity. This was a,
this was a historic site for us.
I mean, it's not the easiest one to get to because it is 50 light years away.
And we know, no, we now know about planets. You know,
there are only a few light years away. Um,
so it's probably not the first one that would ever get visited, but yeah,
when it becomes routine, it will become one of the stops on the tourist trail.
I suspect there's of course there could be other planets in the system, right.
We've just seen this one, um, fairly massive Jupiter, like planet,
very close to the star,
which really wouldn't be very hospitable because it's going to be a gas giant
and it's gonna be very hot and very unpleasant. Um, but who knows,
there could be other planets further out in the solar system.
Father of modern cosmology. Does that mean there's an older cosmology?
Like where does it, where did,
where did old cosmology transition to modern cosmic.
Um, giving the transition time around the 1960s, which by the way,
is another important for the,
that sort of the E pocket Higgs and kibble and browse and uncle Aaron
people, the discovery of the cosmic microwave background radiation.
I think that kind of transformed the field from being one that was
full of speculation and promise in solving Einstein's
equations without really knowing what the background material was in the
universe. To first,
the first time we established that this radiation,
this remnant of the hot,
big bang that emerged when the first atoms were formed,
say 400,000 years after the big bang and then just propagated
outwards for the next 3.8 billion years,
that the detection of that in the 1960s, 1965, in fact,
it was announced by Penzias and Wilson,
that where the associated attention pitcher to this radiation
that's right, I think is what you might call I'm calling here.
That's kind of the start of modern cosmology and peoples was that in fact,
it's not very well known, but, um,
the paper by Penzias and Wilson, which is one page long.
Now we are busting,
I got writing all these long page one page paper about the third or fourth
line, having a name announced that they discovered this radiation,
that they don't really know why it is. They say that in the preceding paper,
in the journal,
which is Jim Peebles paper with decay and roll and
Wilkinson, they say, they've come up with an explanation for what this could be.
And it is in fact, you know, the microwave background,
radiation at a temperature of around at the time,
they say 3.5 Kelvin, um,
sort of it's now about seen as about 2.7 Calvin, but that's that's okay.
It was 3.5 plus or minus 9.1. So they were perfectly okay,
but people was there. And in fact, not only was he there, he, he,
he's the one that actually in the previous paper,
the one that literally appears before, which is a mindblowing four pages long.
So that's a huge paper by comparison.
He's the one along with his coauthors who suggest that actually this
remnant radiation is linked to the hot, big bang, and he,
and that it's got these thermal properties. It's that I think,
which is really key that,
that you can pin down has been one of people's men contributions here that he,
he recognizes the significance of that of the radiation has been linked to the
early universe. And the second thing that he does,
which I hadn't seen done before,
he points out that because we now know the temperature of that radiation.
And because we believe in the idea of general relativity,
and we can understand how that radiation changes its temperature as the
universe changes scale, because it gets redshifted shifted,
it cools down as the universe expands. It means it's hotter earlier on.
And so he's able to link the temperature you've got today to an estimate of what
the amount of matter must be in the universe today,
because he knows what it must be sort of in the,
around the time of nuclear synthesis. He's got a boundary can use.
And by doing that, he actually end this paper without,
I don't think necessarily really realizing that the same,
there must be some sort of dark matter.
He's actually points out that the estimate for the amount of baryons matter
in the universe in terms of barriers is actually lower than the critical
matter amount that you need that we see today.
We believe the universe today is specially flat.
That means there's a critical amount of matter in there.
And he said in his calculations, there's not, there's not enough. And in fact,
at the end of his first paper,
the one that appears with Penzias and Wilson comes up with ways of trying to
increase the amounts, but he was there.
He was pointing out this connection between measurement of the
radiation and the density of matching universe.
And that's absolutely integral to the rest of cosmology. The man in the street,
probably hasn't heard of the land to CDM model,
but I think if you said the standard model of cosmology,
that's what you would say peoples was responsible for the standard model of
cosmology has various contributions to the overall energy budget.
So before peoples was around, we knew that there were baryons right. And, and,
but we didn't necessarily know how many and people began to put a bound on that
from this paper,
but then he made some even bigger contributions in some sense.
The next thing he sorts of realized was that again,
using the fact that you've got this cosmic microwave background that had been
detected by Penzias and Wilson,
he was aware of the fact that this fluctuations to be expected in this cosmic
microwave background. And he's the one along with you who,
who actually was the first to fully do sort of numerical
simulations of different types of cosmology and
predict what the,
the Doppler they acoustic oscillations were that we see in the microwave
background. Remember those peak structures that are big peaks,
and then we'd go down. As you, as in the CMB,
he was the first to numerically show, what different cosmologies would predict.
And so he, in amongst that he showed what a flat universe would do.
And that's the one that pretty much is observed by first of all,
by w map. And then by plank,
the initial anisotropy is with demonstrated by Kobe,
but the original work solving the numerical codes
to show roughly what they would look like is from people's. What made him good?
Like, why is he, why is he good at this?
What is it about him that all the other cosmologists haven't got?
I don't think anybody has his overview.
He's a, his very, very strong mathematically. He he's,
he's developed the statistics that are,
you that's used in much of the analysis of the CMB and of large-scale structure.
When you're looking at correlations of different regions of the sky,
he developed the techniques you need more than that.
And these ability to solve equations and do integrals and things. He had this,
he has, he's still there. He's 85,
but he's still very active and really on the ball. He has this overview,
this, he can see the bigger picture. He can see how we're given calculation.
A given observation tells you something about something else in the
universe by extracting out from that small initial
observation,
that sort of it's impact on the whole of the background evolution. And,
and to do that is not easy too,
because there's so many balls in the air and he's able to juggle them all in
the, and I think that in many ways, this has big scale. Have you ever met him?
Oh yeah. I've met him many times at conferences.
He's such a nice guy is one of these people that,
that is always prepared to give you his time.
If you're walking for dinner or having lunch, or he's, he,
he asks really pertinent questions. And, um,
but he's have always found him to be somebody that has easy to get
on with that. When he asks questions is very polite. And,
but he's not afraid to tell you if you, if he thinks you're wrong,
which he's done to me a couple of times.
Professor, I know in cosmology,
there are kind of different camps and schools of thought, you know,
people who like string theory and a, B and C, and all that is is,
is people's in yours on your side or on the opposite side.
People sit sort of above it all. He,
I don't think he's worried about the camps to be honest.
He's he goes where the science tells him.
Really excited Neil, because it's for lithium batteries.
And so he's gone on a battery Safari.
Some of you know that Neil is a motorcyclist.
He has an electric motorcycle.